vers le début de la soirée n'est pas
celui que nous espérions en toute
hypothèse
ce ne sera pas celui qui a été annoncé
qui sera le bon en effet le ministère de
l'intérieur a réservé sa déclaration
jusqu'à ce soir minuit
bien sûr d'ici là médiacrates et
oligarques jubile rien n'est si beau
pour eux qu'un second tour entre deux
candidats qui approuve et veulent
prolonger les deux des institutions
actuelles qui n'exprime aucune prise de
conscience écologique ni sur le péril
qui pèse sur la civilisation humaine et
qui les deux comptes s'en prendre une
fois de plus aux acquis sociaux les plus
élémentaires du pays
quoi qu'il en soit et quel qu'il soit
lorsque les résultats officiels seront
connus nous les respecterons
je ne saurais dire ni faire davantage à
cette heure
chacun chacune d'entre vous un set en
conscience quel est son devoir
dès lors je me range je n'ai reçu aucun
mandat des quatre cent cinquante mille
personnes qui ont décidé de présenter ma
candidature qui ont exprimé à leur place
sur la suite
elles seront donc appelés à se prononcer
sur la plateforme est le résultat de
leur expression sera rendu public
[Applaudissements]
mon beau pays
ma belle patrie et vous tous les gens
nous pouvons être fiers de ce que nous
avons entrepris et réaliser nous sommes
une force consciente et enthousiaste
je vous appelle à rester groupés à
rester en mouvement et à être un
mouvement car les défis que nous avons
nommé 100 en cash et aucun ni aucune des
difficultés qu'ils soulèvent pour les
régler ces défis restent à relever
et ceux qui prétendent aujourd'hui à
l'honneur de nous représenter tous ont
déjà fait la démonstration qu'ils
étaient incapables même de les panser
leur avenir et les jours qui viennent
restent celles des caractères et de la
conscience vous tous les gens patrie
bien aimé
vous êtes un matin tout neuf qui
commence à percer fidélité est la devise
de la république liberté égalité
fraternité
vive la république vive la france
[Applaudissements]
m
voilà jean luc mélenchon qui attend les
résultats définitifs
voilà pour le le contenu quelques
chiffres